hello darlin oh hello this is Adam Smith
calling from nobelprize.org first of all
many congratulations on the award the
Nobel Prize thank you so here I'm called
millander today as you know and I was
crying I was in shock and I'm still in
shock so great
where were you when you receive the call
I was in a meeting so we normally have
meetings with the lab on the Monday
morning to go through some based on you
had we had such a great discussions I
had another meeting waiting for me so it
was in in the middle of two meetings and
we were discussing the the last parts of
the data and and those phases so if I
think too many exciting things to deal
with it at the same time I suppose
plane so he doesn't know I'm so
frustrated because he can't get in touch
with him that's deeply frustrating yes
when and where does he land so he will
land in Munich and I think he said
around right so so there'll be a posse
of people waiting for him I imagine
waiting out there
so I mean you are a married couple and
it's very unusual for married couples to
receive the Nobel Prize one thinks of
the quarries and the Curie's but what's
the secret of your partnership I think
it's the secret ask after about the
secret of why we could come so far
together okay in in science and I think
that is that we have the same vision we
love to understand and we do that by
talking to each other talking to other
people and
try to address the questions that we
interested in in in the best way that we
can think of so and and and to be able
to to discuss this when you get an idea
on the spot instead of plan a meeting in
one or two or three weeks that makes a
huge difference so there's a lot of
spontaneity about it yeah and and it's
it's so funny because you know we have
the caffeine which is there and we had
this meeting with recovery directors and
they said yeah and then we have to plan
all these meetings and some of them easy
for us because we can have a breakfast
meeting so almost every day and of
course when you when you want to select
your colleagues you want to have
colleagues to respect you who you can
trust and who would support you and I
think that is the clue exactly exactly
talking of colleagues you of course know
your codori at John Okeefe very well
yeah so fantastic you know he was he was
supervising us how to start to do these
recordings in 95
in the summer 95 yeah and you've
remained close ever since yes I think
it's also so extremely important to say
that this is honor for all the people
who have supported excellent science in
Norway
of course our group family but all sort
of local people are attempted and the
politicians and the Research Council all
have been extremely extremely supportive
to us and I think it wouldn't have been
possible if if that wouldn't be the case
that's very nice and so it's a
celebration not just for neuroscience
but also for Norwegian Saturday and also
that people trusted us supported us it's
it's a celebration on that
lovely well many many congratulations
again and thank you so much thank you
enjoy thank you bye bye